today we're gonna talk about the strange
things you can do with liquids I'm
talking about smart liquids hi my name
is Aneesa Ramirez welcome to science
explained now water is already a very
strange liquid just think about it it's
solid form is less dense than its liquid
form
that's why ice floats now there's things
that we can do to water and to other
liquids to make them even more strange
or as scientists would say smart we can
make water or liquids respond to a
magnet these liquids are called
ferrofluids I have one right here
now on its own it looks like a liquid
however when I apply a strong magnet to
it I get really strange behavior it
thickens and it starts looking very
spiky that's very cool so where do we
use ferrofluids well we use them to seal
hard disks we can also use them to treat
cancer we do this by bringing the
ferrofluid to a tumor and then heating
it up with a fluctuating magnetic field
artists love it too because they can
make really funky structures with these
materials so let's say you want to make
a ferrofluid at home well you can do
that what you need is an iron fortified
cereal and very strong magnet and some
water you see if you get the cereal and
you put it in a bag and crush it up so
that it looks like this you'll notice
that when you apply a very strong magnet
to it small pieces will actually come up
to the magnet you see when they said
iron fortified they really weren't
joking there's small bits of iron within
the cereal now if you put that into a
plastic bag add a little water you'll
have a ferrofluid and a little bit of a
mess so you see liquids aren't boring
they're actually pretty amazing when you
add things to them they can do stuff
that you never would have imagined I'm
an Easter ramírez thank you for joining
me at science explained and I hope that
you'll come back for another edition